President Trump faces rare backlash from
his own party for his decision to
withdraw US troops from northern Syria
new video this morning shows more
American forces leaving the area near
the Turkish border
clearing the way for Turkey to attack
Kurdish fighters who were crucial US
allies in the fight against Isis the
president's decision reportedly was a
shock to other officials many of his
Republican supporters call it a betrayal
and a mistake which threatens to upset
everything the US was trying to
accomplish in the region
Ouisa jiang is at the White House we
shall have the Turks actually started
attacking yet oh good morning Anthony no
but turkey says all preparations for a
possible military operation in northern
Syria are complete a move US
intelligence believes could happen
within 12 to 36 hours the Pentagon has
made clear it does not support a Turkish
incursion but the White House has
offered conflicting messages about where
it stands we have to bring our people
back home during a briefing with
military leaders last night President
Trump defended his decision to withdraw
American troops from northern Syria we
were down to very few soldiers in Syria
we had 50 in the region that you're
talking about 50 soldiers and they've
been already moved out these images
captured the US troops deserting
observation posts and abandoning the
us-backed Kurdish forces that have
shouldered much of the fight against
Isis too many times America in the past
has left our allies behind some of the
president's staunchest Republican allies
in Congress wasted no time condemning
his decision pat toomey called it a
threat to our national security
Liz Cheney described it as a
catastrophic mistake and Lindsey Graham
said it's a shot in the arm to the bad
guys devastating for the good guys even
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell said the
move would increase the risk that Isis
and other terrorist groups regroup I
respect both opinions the problem with
the other opinion is when do we leave
when do we leave we're gonna stay there
forever the fear of a resurgence by Isis
stems partly from the possibility that
an attack by Turkey could jeopardize the
security of prisons controlled by the
Kurds
that hold roughly 10,000 Isis prisoners
about 2,500 of whom are highly dangerous
foreign fighters the White House
statement Sunday said Turkey would take
custody of foreign fighters after first
saying Turkey will soon be moving
forward with its long planned operation
in northern Syria president Trump
changed his tune tweeting if turkey does
anything that I in my great and
unmatched wisdom considered to be
off-limits I will totally obliterate the
economy of Turkey there are roughly
1,000 US troops in northeastern Syria
and the administration says for now
there is no plan to leave all together
this morning CBS News has learned that
former senior advisors to President
Trump are watching and they are
concerned that there are few voices left
here who can dissuade him from making
sudden decisions and advise him on
making smart moves from everything on
foreign policy like this to the
impeachment inquiry that is hanging over
the White House
Tony delicate situation there we should
thank you very much